ich habe mein handy dabei wieder 1000
euro schlüsseldienst und genau deswegen
hat sich ist so stumpf in läden zu gehen
und das zu film- oder so und ich habe
mir diese
[Musik]
hey leute was geht abwärts willkommen
bei einem mit veolia und ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut
also es könnte besser sein und zwar
haben wir ein kleines problem vorliegen
ich bin gestern zurück nach köln
gefahren und heute ist sonntag
ja ich war jetzt zwei wochen bei meinen
eltern habt ihr vielleicht mitbekommen
auf instagram oder snatch advice mir
auch nicht falsch und ich muss mich mal
kurz was zeiten kommen sie mit wenn man
sich den kühlschrank anschaut gut hier
sind zwar noch sachen drin wie käse
nutella eine gurke dieses zeugs hier und
noch mehr brotaufstrich wir haben nicht
mal mehr eine tiefkühlpizza
ja das sieht auch nicht so lecker aus
mozzarella stick also ich muss man ganz
klar sagen wirklich was vernünftiges zu
essen ist nicht weil das könnt ihr
wahrscheinlich alle das problem einem
sonntag genau es hat kein geschäft auf
aussah hier in köln am flughafen der
supermarkt der ist offen im auto ist man
da auch mindestens eine halbe stunde
unterwegs da habe ich keinen bock
deswegen habe ich mir folgendes überlegt
ich weiß nicht ob wir dieses video von
mir gesehen habt nur automaten produkte
essen 24 stunden challenge war das ist
ja sogar schon zwei monate her da kam
das online ja und einige fahren ist ganz
lustig und das ding ist die einzigen
geschäfte die heute offen haben sind
halt tankstellen wir haben hier in der
umgebung mega viele tankstellen und ich
habe mir gedacht machen wir doch einfach
mal 24 stunden also theoretisch schon 24
stunden seit sonntagmorgen 24 stunden
nur tankstellen produkte
natürlich ist das eine sache die heute
jetzt erstmal ungesund an muss aber gar
nicht heißen dass es so ungesund wie er
will gar nicht lange gelagert wir fahren
los und mal sehen was der tag sollte
bringt und vor allem wie teuer ist wird
das war ja beim letzten mal auch sehr
interessant ich glaube für die automaten
produkte habe ich so an die 30 euro
bezahlt auf jeden fall schon nicht
günstig mal gucken aber das heute toppen
oder nicht also ich würde sagen lassen
dann nach oben da wenn ihr bock drauf
habe aber nicht vergessen weil wir sind
immer noch bei 30 prozent von euch
dieses video show haben abonniert auch
jeder auf jeden fall jetzt den kanal und
dann geht es los zuerst eine tankstelle
früchte kohlen
[Musik]
so wird also ich habe schon gesagt
werden in der umgebung eine menge
tankstelle also wirklich richtig viele
einige davon den ganz normalen gestellt
andere noch so richtig wird im shop
dabei und wir fahren jetzt erstmals in
einer tankstelle mit dicken shop dran
weil die haben halt auch mehr
und vielleicht könnte man heute auch mal
so ein bisschen überprüfen ob tankstelle
gleich teuer sind oder ob es da
vielleicht unterschiede gekommen ein
auto steht sofort vorne so leute wir
sind dabei wenn man das sehen kann ich
finds mal so unangenehm ich kann man das
irgendwie reinzulaufen deswegen gehe ich
ohne kann man rein so leute wieder da
ich habe mir jetzt folgendes geholt und
man kann sich 100 prozent als frühstück
abstempeln aber das war auch schwerer
wasser ganz wichtig für 90 cent da haben
wir hier eine butterbrezel durstlöscher
doch nicht immer getrunken und so was
habe ich noch nie gesehen und wir haben
jetzt eine pizza also ich habe eben
gesagt so willst sicherlich nicht aber
dass ich jetzt suchen staat
wahrscheinlich mich grad selber für
eigentlich hatte ich auch was anderes
kaufen können egal
es gibt ja noch andere mahlzeiten
[Musik]
hier steckt einmal von der anderen seite
noch ein schlüssel dann habe ich
überhaupt nicht ich habe nicht mal mein
handy dabei geil wieder 1000 euro
defekten schlüsseldienst mache mir
sorgen um sein
in einer dritten klasse dass man
die station soll dann gibt's auch
endlich umsetzen
ich habe es die ganze selber versucht
aber es klappt nicht das habe ich einen
schlüsseldienst gerufen
ich hasse schritte hinter diesen so
teuer und er muss mir jetzt die türken
das vom liebes die türen sind so neu und
wir kann man irgendwie keiner alten
tricks anwenden es in die kommentare was
tippt ihr wie teuer wird der
schlüsseldienst ich bin mal gespannt
gleich kommt ihr auflösen
[Musik]
also seid mir nicht böse wenn ich auf
dieses video einmal mehr werbung
geschaltet
2000 jahre später wollte ich musste
jetzt für nun spaß 95 euro zahlen
jetzt haltet euch fest eigentlich muss
man aber an sonn und feiertagen das
doppelte zahlen regen hatte damals
gesehen auch eigentlich korrekt sehen
also ich weiß gerade wirklich einfach
drei stunden draußen ich musste zwei
stunden waren zweieinhalb stunden keine
ahnung ich habe gedacht jetzt schon gar
nicht mehr
aber jetzt schon überhaupt keinen bock
mehr auf den tag so leute nächste
tankstelle ich war jetzt gerade wieder
und habe mixa selbst unter wasser
45 euro hat das problem ist die hat man
nur so richtig wenig vernünftiges zu
essen also was man wirklich als mahlzeit
bezeichnet kann das meiste sind
irgendwelche snacks draußen wird es
langsam auf jeden fall schon okay ich
habe ja gerade zum ersten mal anfechten
ich habe mich gerade auch mal gefragt
wieso ich immer wieder losfahren
obwohl es ja schon ganz cool ist eine
andere tankstelle zu testen er wird
jetzt einfach mal was wir noch so
bekomme ich habe die größte
tankstellennetz im visier
und ich könnte auf jeden fall sowieso
mal tanken weil morgen geht es noch ein
bisschen höher was gibt es zum
abendessen ich muss sagen so nudeln wenn
ich schlecht aber da nicht mal gespannt
bis gleich
[Applaus]
und genau deswegen hatte ich es so
stumpf in läden zu gehen und das zu
filmen oder so weil halt die leute vor
allem die kassierer einen immer bis zum
angucken
gerade ich zeige euch gleich was sie mir
jetzt geholt habe er guckt mich so die
ganze bibel stumpf an weil ich halt die
kamera mit in der hand habe ich habe
mich nachher kommen jetzt setzen wir
hier bisher nicht einfach mit scheiß
drauf er guckt mich an sagt oder salaten
jetzt berühmt ich sage hey wieso also ja
was ist das denn dafür eine kamera bis
zur youtuber oder was ich so ladies aus
ich habe mich schnell ausgemacht weil
ich da jetzt mal kurz anhalten
und er fragt mich dann so ja wofür
brauchst das denn und ich hab so gedacht
was rede ich das überhaupt so an weiße
oder ein sicherer der korrekt aber keine
ahnung dann habe ich halt gesagt also
was spaß auch bisschen beruflich und er
dann so ach so ja diese youtuber ja
generell ganz schlimm wie viele follower
war die alle haben und wie viel wir
haben mit dann auch noch verdienen und
wie für die gesponsert bekommen nicht
sagst du die ganze komplett genauso wie
so eine scheiße die ja von sich geben
hätte ich das mal aufgenommen wenn ich
habe keinen halt ausgemacht ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe dann auch
einfach irgendwas genommen weil ich
schon gesehen habe wie dumm da mich die
ganze zeit ankommt diesen drink für 130
habe ich früher einmal getrunken
eigentlich cool und ich weiß nicht ob
ihr das video von mir gesehen habe wo
ich sushi das erst mal probiert habe
eigentlich hatte ich immer das gefühl
ich mag das nicht habe jetzt einfach mal
so viel geld hat drei euro fünfzig
gekostet sondern auch schon rice
aufgedreht 50 also ich habe für das
alles insgesamt irgendwie 9 euro bezahlt
ich muss es nach gucken ob ich auf dem
kassenzettel blende ich natürlich hier
ein
wir fahren jetzt erst mal nach hause
wirklich sehr lecker vor allem die hier
mit paprika ist glaube ich drin
sushi und wie heißt das riesenreich
salat ist das kein plan
dann habe ich mir überlegt ich gucke
später war da hinten ist
es ist wirklich richtig angenehm haben
jetzt 10 uhr halb elf von glaube ich ja
und ich hab mir grad einfach mal gedacht
wenn ich das jetzt schon mache ich habe
auch so eine tankstelle hier um die ecke
bei uns ja irgendwie 24 stunden offen
da gehe ich jetzt noch mal hin mal
gucken was die so haben will ich sonst
natürlich nicht machen aber für das
video gerne aber wir haben einfach schon
halb zwölf habe ich mich irgendwie ein
bisschen verschätzt wenn man jetzt mal
alles so zusammen richtig leuchten schon
weit über 25 euro und bitte also 25 euro
ungefähr gut denn dann eigentlich noch
plus 5 90 euro wegen dem schlüsseldienst
das wäre ja eigentlich sonst nicht
passiert obwohl dann welche
wahrscheinlich auch irgendwann muss ich
jetzt unter ganze muss man schon die
tankstelle kann man es sehen wtf geht
bei diesem auto alter was das denn ich
habe auf jeden fall ein heftiges autos
am start was haltet ihr von so marken
blocking oder wie das heißt cup adidas
adidas
also wir haben hier snack und da gehe
ich doch über roths trade machen hat
sich auf jeden fall schon mal nicht
schlecht an
kennt ihr diese seven eleven wo ich in
dänemark war da ist alles voll mit
diesem geil aber dazu müssen wir die
bahn stehen wir sind 24 stunden für sie
da hier ist ihm danke
das geht jetzt
eigentlich wollte ich nur kurz hier
abmoderation drehen
aber irgendwie ist es dazu laut und das
stinkt und ich habe mir diese cookies
hier gut
das problem ist immer wenn man abends
irgendwo so videos dreht alle leute
denken ich will irgendwo einbrechen will
ich ja gar nicht habe ich war noch nie
gesehen und zuerst weiß ich mich nur
frage schaut euch das mal an da ist ja
wirklich null ähnlichkeit merken
natürlich nur noch ein anti
alkoholisches getränk gekommen so weit
ich habe das video jetzt auf jeden fall
schon fertig geschnitten und auch
gefeiert habe glaub' ich insgesamt so 25
26 euro bezahlen ich habe es jetzt nicht
auf den cent genau durchgerechnet und
jeder weiß ja dass tankstellen extrem
teuer sind das heißt wenn ihr jetzt zum
beispiel alleine wohnt bald achtet immer
darauf dass irgendwas zu hause hab
trotzdem hätte ich natürlich jetzt auch
theoretisch drei mal bestellen können
deswegen war das gleich rausgekommen gut
werden wahrscheinlich habe ein bisschen
um gesünder geworden
ich glaube an sich war ich ganz
zufrieden war auf jeden fall wenn es
nicht leute ich würde sagen das war's
mit dem tag das war haben im video kann
sich gefeiert das ist auf jeden fall
einmal nach oben da abonnieren nicht
vergessen ganz wichtig wir werden immer
mehr das freut mich und mein ziel ist
halt einfach eine million ist ja klar da
freuen wenn ihr abonnieren wird wenn wir
sehen uns morgen wieder um 14 uhr ab
reichen heute